esta de aquí es la gráfica de x más
igual a 1 y supongamos que la región que
se encuentra debajo de esta recta en el
primer cuadrante forma la base de una
figura tridimensional así es que esta
región que tenemos aquí es la base de
una figura tridimensional y lo que
sabemos de esta figura tridimensional es
que si tomamos secciones transversales
que son perpendiculares al eje x
secciones transversales que también
podríamos decir que son paralelas al eje
y supongamos que esta es una de esas
secciones transversales y sabemos que
dichas secciones tienen forma de
semicírculo así es que desde otra
perspectiva la figura tridimensional se
vería como esto el plano coordenada lo
he puesto horizontal de tal manera que
esta sección transversal cuando vemos la
figura desde arriba esta sección
transversal la veríamos si la figura
fuera transparente la veríamos que tiene
esta forma así es cómo veríamos la
sección transversal desde esa
perspectiva donde podemos apreciar que
es un semicírculo esta sección
transversal
del eje y corresponde a esta sección
transversal aquí que como puedes ver es
un semicírculo más grande dada esta
información te invito a que le pongas
pausa al vídeo e intentes calcular cuál
es el volumen de esta cosa de esta
figura tridimensional que he intentado
dibujar aquí trata de calcular cuál es
el volumen de este sólido tridimensional
supongo que ya lo intentaste y vamos
ahora a hacerlo juntos una manera de
abordar este problema es dividir el
sólido en muchas rebanadas que
corresponden a las secciones
transversales que hemos marcado si
calculamos el volumen de cada una de
estas rebanadas transversales y
posteriormente sumamos todos esos
volúmenes vamos a tener una muy buena
aproximación del volumen del sólido
completo y si posteriormente tomamos el
límite cuando tenemos un número infinito
de rebanadas infinitamente pequeñas
obtendremos el valor exacto del volumen
empecemos calculando entonces la
aproximación consideremos esta rebanada
que se encuentra en él
cuál va a ser entonces el diámetro de
esta rebanada semicircular cuál es el
diámetro de la rebanada semicircular que
se encuentra en x para ver esto tenemos
que reescribir esta ecuación tenemos que
despejar 10 para reescribir la de la
forma igual a efe x es decir que igual a
1 - x así es que el diámetro de este
semicírculo déjame indicarlo claramente
aquí el diámetro de este semicírculo
corresponde a esta longitud es la
diferencia entre 1 - x y el eje x entre
1 - x y x igual a 0
así es que esta longitud que corresponde
al diámetro va a estar dada como función
de x por 1 - x ahora si queremos
encontrar el área de la sección
transversal es decir el área del
semicírculo sabemos que el área del
círculo es pi por radio al cuadrado por
lo cual el área de un semicírculo va a
estar dada como pi por radio al cuadrado
sobre 2
así es que cuál es el radio que
corresponde
a los semicírculos así es que el radio
lo puedo dibujar aquí estoy haciendo mi
mejor esfuerzo para dibujar estos
semicírculos se ven más o menos así con
cierta perspectiva así es que el radio
es la mitad del diámetro el diámetro es
1 - x con lo cual el radio es 1 x sobre
2 esta distancia es 1 - x sobre 2 está
aquí también es 1 - x sobre 2 y está
aquí también es 1 - x sobre 2 así es que
este radio mide 1 - x sobre 2 este es el
valor del radio
así es que cuál será cuál será el área d
este lado esta cara lateral de la
rebanada bien el área del círculo es
pipo radio al cuadrado pero al ser un
semicírculo el área es y por radio al
cuadrado sobre 2 vamos a escribirlo aquí
área es igual a y por radio al cuadrado
sobre 2 pues es un semicírculo ahora
podemos escribir el área como una
función de x
para que nos quede a de x es igual a pis
sobre 2
es igual a pis sobre 2 que multiplica al
radio al cuadrado que es 1 - x sobre 2
que multiplica a 1 - x sobre 2 y todo
esto elevado al cuadrado ahora
necesitamos calcular el volumen de esta
rebanada que tenemos aquí para lo cual
tengo que multiplicar esa área por el
espesor simplemente tengo que
multiplicar esa área por el espesor que
tenemos aquí dicho espesor lo podemos
denotar como de equis o más precisamente
como delta x así es que este espesor es
delta x así es que multiplicamos esto
por delta x éste es nuestro
de hecho déjame ser más preciso esta de
ahí es más bien el área y aquí voy a
escribir el volumen el volumen de cada
rebanada va a estar dado por pi sobre 2
que multiplica a 1 - x sobre 2 elevado
al cuadrado multiplicado por el espesor
que ya vimos que es delta x esto es el
volumen el volumen
cada rebanada de
rebanada así es que el volumen del
sólido lo podemos aproximar como la suma
de todas estas o podemos tomar el límite
a medida que delta x se hace cada vez
más y más pequeño y tenemos cada vez más
y más de estas lo cual como ya sabemos
es calcular la integral definida hagamos
eso tenemos entonces que el volumen de
toda esta cosa el volumen de este sólido
es igual a la integral definida desde
que x igual a cero hasta que x es igual
a 1 es donde la recta intercepta el eje
x desde que x igual a cero hasta x igual
a 1 d estamos sumando los volúmenes de
un número infinito de rebanadas a medida
que su espesor se hace infinitamente
pequeño así es que la integral de déjame
hacerlo con este color y sobre dos de 1
- x al cuadrado lo voy a desarrollar de
una vez lo voy a desarrollar
1 - x al cuadrado es lo mismo que x
menos 1 al cuadrado lo cual es x
cuadrada menos 2 x más 1 y todo eso
dividido entre 2 al cuadrado que es 4
en lugar de delta x voy a poner de equis
pues estoy tomando el límite cuando
delta x se hace infinitamente pequeño y
estoy sumando un número infinito de
estos así es que para calcular el
volumen simplemente tenemos que evaluar
esta integral definida y si te sientes
inspirada expirado puedes ponerle pausa
al vídeo y tratar de evaluar esto por tu
cuenta bien para empezar saquemos estas
constantes de la integral
tenemos entonces que el volumen es igual
y sobre 8
que multiplica a la integral definida
desde 0 hasta 1
de x cuadrada menos 2 x 1 de x y esto es
igual a ti sobre 8 que multiplica la
anti derivada de esto que es x cúbicas
sobre 3 - x cuadrada más x y esto lo
vamos a evaluar desde que x es igual a
cero hasta que x es igual a 1 y esto es
igual a
y sobre 8 que multiplica a evaluamos la
expresión en 1 este es un tercio menos
uno más uno es un tercio y cuando
evaluamos en 0 es 0 - 0 0 esto es 0 así
es que simplemente y sobre 8 por un
tercio lo cual es igual a pi sobre 24 y
así hemos concluido